“This episode of DNews is brought to you
by the Toyota Prius. Let’s lead the way.”
Teenagers don’t get enough sleep, because
they’re up late making bad decisions, right?
But what if it’s the other way around? But
could their lack of sleep lead to partying?
Hey everyone, julia here for DNews
Teenagers don’t get enough sleep, some studies
say almost half of American teenagers don’t
get enough sleep. But maybe that’s because
they’re forced into a schedule counter to
their biological clocks. Their internal clocks
tick a little later than full grown adults.
They sleep longer and stay awake later. Yet
thanks to early start times for high schools,
they often get less than 7 of their recommended
9-9 ½ hours of sleep.
A recent study published in the journal Alcoholism:
Clinical and Experimental Research, suggests
that sleep problems in teenagers mean more
than just an attitude and poor grades. Trouble
sleeping or not getting enough sleep strongly
predicted not just alcohol use, but associated
problematic behaviors, like binge-drinking,
driving under the influence and risky sexual
behavior.
Previous studies show a relation between sleep
problems and substance abuse in high risk
populations, but this study controlled for
that. These were kids who, for whatever reason
weren’t sleeping enough.
The researchers looked at data collected from
interviews and questionnaires from The National
Longitudinal Study of Adolescent to Adult
Health. The data was collected in three waves,
1st wave 1994 to 1995; second wave: 1996;
third wave: 2001 to 2002. Controlling for
previous substance abuse, those sleepy high
schoolers in the mid-90s, were more likely
to have drinking problems 6 or 7 years later.
The researchers found that having trouble
sleeping or not getting enough sleep in the
1st wave strongly predicted alcohol problems
in the 2nd wave, the prediction for alcohol
issues in the third wave was less strong but
still significant.
While some of sleepiness can be attributed
to an unfriendly schedule, the rates of insomnia
and sleep issues reported in this study were
about the same for adults. One in ten reported
chronic insomnia while three in ten report
occasional insomnia. This points to a biological
basis for sleeping problems.
This isn’t the first study to show a correlation
between being tired and making bad decisions.
Studies often show not getting enough sleeps
inhibits self-regulation, something teens
already struggle with.
Why do teens struggle more than the rest of
us? Well mainly because their pre-frontal
cortex isn’t fully developed yet. This part
of the brain sits just behind the forehead
and it’s important for what’s called “executive
functioning”. Things like planning, memory,
organization and mood. More importantly in
the case of the sleepy teens, this part of
the brain helps you weigh the cost and benefits
of your choices.
Studies show that a lack of sleep reduces
activity in this part of the brain, this disruption
increases risk taking behavior. It’s easy
to see how poor sleep and the teenage brain
combine and can lead to bad decisions. Being
a teenager and being sleep deprived is a double
whammy for the prefrontal cortex.
So if you’re a teen, get more sleep. Seriously.
If you’re a parent of a teen, help them
get the sleep they need. You might try to
talk to them about how important sleep is
for the developing brain. Keep them on a regular
sleep schedule and cut out electronics like
phones and laptops before bed. It could help
curb some of the more dangerous of adolescent
behaviors.
To learn more about why teenagers need more
sleep or to find out why you need to sleep
at all, check these videos below.
So, throwing it back to you commenters, is
partying late really that excellent? Do you
party because you’re sleep deprived? Comment
below! oh and don’t forget to hit that subscribe
button!
Let us know! We can be found on the twitter
@Dnews